ps4 update 3.5 is out in the wild but it
changes a lot more than remote play and
social features there's a bunch of
hidden stuff we didn't know about until
now I'm Tony and this game spot news
update will bring you up to speed first
off you can now play music off of a USB
stick a feature that was originally
removed back in September if you're
upgrading your hard drive soon you'll be
happy to know that the ps4 now supports
drives as big as 4 terabytes and if you
like using the live from PlayStation app
there's more good news it's easier to
search for specific games now and you
can pin your favorites to the search
field which will bring up the
appropriate live streams much more
quickly finally there's an option to
turn off the screenshot notification and
new editing options in the capture
gallery your ps4 might feel like a whole
new console after all that ps4 update
3.5 just released on april six so we
might dig up even more hidden features
in the coming days for now there are
plenty of options to make the things you
like to do easier to do not to mention
that whole playing ps4 games on your
computer thing for now you can stick
with gamespot for all the latest on
playstation
you